there is no work life balance there's
just life the fact that we are
separating work from life I think is a
big problem I think that's why most
people hate their life because we don't
see work as a part of life your work is
a part of life we all want to wake up
and feel like we matter and we're going
to do something today in our work that's
going to create some kind of positive
impact right on the days when you wake
up and you feel like today is going to
matter I'm going to make something that
is going to matter to another human
being maybe a million people maybe
person but today is going to matter
those are the days that you love your
life and you feel amazing and you feel
like you're contributing and you feel
like this is yes this is why I do what I
do and on the days when you feel like it
doesn't matter nobody cares if you show
up you're not making anything meaningful
there is no contribution those are the
days where you hate your life hey it's
EV Carmichael and I watch these videos
every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goal goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hash believe in the comments below so I
can celebrate with
you want to sore get a mentor hey it's
Nina carmichel and we made these videos
it's probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you need
to p first by surround yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan carmichel the
reason why most people hate dear life
enjoy when I'm on podcast and people ask
me this question like what does work
life balance mean to you or they ask me
some variation of it like how many hours
a day do you work or what does your work
calendar look like it's like well what
what's work to you is my usual response
now I'm sitting here on your show I'm
having a great time we're doing this
podcast together
is is this work for
you like does this count as work cuz I
don't see this as work this isn't work
this is fun this is fun for me this is
my life I like this when I see this
podcast in my calendar I'm excited by it
I don't look at it as work making these
videos I don't see it as work that's why
I've been able to stay so
consistent right how do I not burn out
it's another question to G A how do you
not burn out how you make so many videos
how do you not burn out a lot of people
burn out nowhere even close to the
number of videos that that I've done
over how many years 13 years a lot of
years guys it's been a lot of years of
showing up and
making over 10,000 videos crazy how why
well because it doesn't feel like work
this this is part of my life it's a it's
this is what a purposeful life looks
like if I saw it as work I would have
quit qu and given up years ago I mean a
decade plus ago there are some pieces of
what I do that feels like work you know
doing accounting stuff feels like work I
hate that stuff doing administrative
stuff paperwork legal stuff that feels
like work I burn out very quickly I
don't want to spend I want to spend the
least amount of time as possible on that
I want to hire people have a great
lawyer have a great accountant H have a
great bookkeeper have people help me
with that stuff cuz I do not enjoy it it
feels like work and if my calendar was
just filled with that stuff I would hate
my life so I I don't I don't believe in
work life balance I I reject the the
premise of the entire question it's just
life how do you want to spend your life
and this is one of the greatest things
that we have is entrepreneurs you get to
decide what your life is you get to pick
the business you go into you don't have
a boss besides the customers but you
still also get to pick which customers
that you work with and your your work
should be something that is a source of
joy for you and a source of energy for
you because when you love what you're
doing every day it will bring you a lot
more happiness and satisfaction in your
life so it's all just life one of the
great things I think that you can do is
look at your calendar see what's coming
up in the next couple weeks couple
months and are you excited by the things
that are in your calendar and I I put
everything in my calendar I I love
living by my calendar
um I don't know if it's because I don't
remember what I'm doing you know
tomorrow I'm so present focused that I
don't know what's I don't know what I'm
supposed to be doing tomorrow so I have
it in my calendar and it I think it also
reduces anxiety for me to know that I've
got days for things so making videos I
don't worry during the week about making
videos because I know on Tuesday it's my
video day and I'll get it all done and
if I get an idea for video I'll email
myself and I'll look at that on Tuesday
so it's in my calendar so I have I have
a spot for everything so I'm not
constantly worried before I had a
calendar I'd be worried and anxious
about oh when am I going to get this
done when do I have time to do this and
that would stress me out where now like
okay I know on I'm going to do that on
Tuesday when are we going to have time
to Mentor my team well okay we're going
to have Monday when are we going to have
time to have you know
um clean up the condo and and do grocery
shopping whatever okay that's Sunday
right so it's all in the calendar so at
least for me having a calendar has been
lifechanging but what ends up happening
is we we don't put everything in our
calendar we just put our meetings in our
calendar where I put everything I put I
put time with n in my calendar time with
my son in my calendar uh time playing
League of Legends and Minecraft is in my
calendar you know you know stuff is it's
in my calendar so I have I have time to
get everything I want out of life done
you have time this this reason of I
don't have time you have time like if I
was to step into your life and see what
you were doing every day there's a lot
of waste of time it's a lot of
unintentional
time so the whole idea of having a
calendar is to be more intentional be
more intentional with how you're
spending your time and if you do that
then you can look at your week ahead
your month ahead and are you excited
this is all life right forget we Lu
balance it's all life so you look at
your life what's in your calendar are
you excited by the things that are in
there are you excited by the projects
you're working on are you excited by the
people you're going to be connecting
with are you excited by the amount of
time you're spending just to yourself
whether that's meditation or yoga or
working out or swimming or walking or
whatever are you spending enough time
just for you are you excited about the
life that is in your C calendar and if
not then change it what are we doing
here this is why you became an
entrepreneur if you want to live
somebody else's version of your life go
get a job where you're told what to do
you're told when to show up you're told
what you have to work on that's that's a
job that's why most people hate their
lives cuz they're being told what to do
constantly all the time they have no
Freedom if you want to be an
entrepreneur and have ultimate
Freedom then let's take control of our
calendar because we're not most
entrepreneurs that I made are feel like
out of
control are wasting a ton of time feel
like they're not spending their time
being intentional know they're capable
of so much more know they can be a lot
more efficient a lot more productive a
lot more purposeful with how they're
spending their time so if there's
nothing in your calendar that's exciting
you then you you do not like your life
because your calendar is reflection of
how you're spending your life so change
it now maybe that's a drastic change or
maybe that's a minor
change and this is an ongoing Evolution
whenever I
feel
unhappy uh not like depressed because
that doesn't really happen but when I'm
feeling when I'm feeling like the energy
is off probably a better way to put it
whenever feel like the energy is off for
one day not the end of the world right
for one day just go do the thing that's
in your calendar cuz you said you were
going to do it right but if that's
happening for a couple days in a row or
if it's happening for Tuesdays is my
filming day for example if I had two or
three Tuesdays in a row where I feel the
energy is really off and I'm not
enjoying making
videos then I need to Pivot and it's
either I need
to make different kinds of
videos or I need to just stop making
videos that may happen I'm willing to
drop things if it doesn't bring me joy
anymore and we as humans stay in things
for far too long like there are things
that you're holding on to that you
should have dropped dropped maybe years
ago and you're still doing it why
because it's a habit a routine or or it
sunk cost like you had this goal 5 years
ago that doesn't even matter to you
anymore but you've built your self
identity around it be willing to let go
of things sooner because you'll never
win doing work that you hate and so
there may come a day where I just
dropped my YouTube channel all of them
cuz it Doesn't fill me with joy anymore
now I don't think that's going to happen
anytime soon cuz I still love doing this
stuff
rule number two don't tie yourself Worth
to winning you're afraid of
experimenting because you tie yourself
Worth to winning instead of trying if
you base your self worth off how much
you win then you're only going to try
things that you have a good chance of
winning at thus you play small for life
but instead if you base your self worth
on trying on the effort that you're
putting in you will fail on most days
but you'll end up accomplishing more
than you ever thought was possible so
every time I go to YouTube event I'm
always being praised by my thumbnails
people always say Evan's got the best
thumbnails go look at his thumbnails
model his thumbnails use them as an
example for the best practice and I I
internally am always saying our
thumbnails suck we need to get better
sure we might be among the best but we
need to get better we could be way
better than we are right now why have we
become the best because I'm
experimenting constantly most of my
tests do not work I use a tool called
tuddy shout out Tu buddy huge fan and
we've done over 1,00 split tests on our
thumbnails where we Ron one thumbnail
against another and one against another
and one against another trying to beat
our best and most of the experiments
don't work they just don't work I
recently ran an experiment of on my main
Channel putting my face on the thumbnail
with the Youtube white border uh against
Tony Robbins and it tanked it was like
80%
worse than our current thumbnail and
that's okay people don't like my face
next to Tony Romans that that is okay
I'm fine with it I expect to lose I
expect everything I do not to work but
I'm willing to test it to see I just
recently came up with one thumbnail
design where I made the background
purple instead of black purple instead
of black and it actually did better it
did significantly better and so now I'm
testing it out on five more thumbnails
to see does the purple one do better
than the black one if that works out
maybe I roll it out across the entire
Channel but it's very rare that I find
the win out of the 11 00 experiments
that we've done most of them will not
work will never work even from the
beginning I'm thinking this is probably
not going to work but I'm willing to
test that's okay even if the most likely
outcome is failure it's worth the test
to see I think we've been conditioned so
much that failing is bad that when you
fail you suck and everybody ridicules
you and and then that's the end the
people who have won the most have failed
the most Jeff Bezos has failed the most
he's tried so many things and most of
them do not work out and that's fine
people don't see the losses when when
you've got a couple wins under your belt
how do you get to the wins through all
the losses right most people they take
one bet they lose because you don't know
what you're doing the first time out you
lose and then you never get back and do
it again you never get up and try again
you settle for a mediocre life because
you're not meant to be an entrepreneur
you're not meant to be an exper you can
never make it and you tell the story to
yourself you just failed once that's all
you should you should suck at the
beginning most things should fail at the
beginning if you start studying success
and I've studied more successful people
than most people you'll see that it's a
history of losses and failures and
defeats in the micro that then they
learn from and they find one thing that
works and then they push all their chips
in and goal in on that thing that's the
only difference they're not any more
special than you they just are more
willing to experiment to try and to fail
now I've got a three-step process to
help you experiment more and stop caring
so much what other people think that I
think will help step number one is
expect to suck at the start just expect
to suck it's crazy how people expect to
be great the first time out the first
thumbnail that you're you're going to
make is going to suck the first person
that you hire on your team is going to
suck not because they suck it's because
you suck as a manager as a trainer as a
leader in hiring you suck it's your
fault look at most companies and look at
the first 10 people that they hired big
companies those 10 people aren't around
anymore because the entrepreneur found
they're sucked at hiring you will hire
the wrong person it doesn't mean that
you can never hire people who should
always be a solo entrepreneur you just
don't have that skill set yet okay
awesome the first video that you make
will suck go back and watch my first
videos they all sucked I was completely
embarrassed by the first 350 public
videos on my channel completely
embarrassed could not watch them back
ever awesome keep going you're going to
step up to the free throw line and try
to shoot a basketball you're not going
to get it in the first time you just
won't I think actually if you're great
the first time out then you actually
suck like if you get on camera and you
make your first video and you're you're
great you suck you should have started
four years ago you should have started
way before you've waited too long you're
sleeping and sitting on your talent so
expect a suck expect the first thing to
have zero results and you're just paying
attention to did you enjoy the process I
may have sucked at making videos at the
beginning but I liked it I liked the
process and I slowly got better and with
time and effort and practice and
patience I got better 6,000 videos later
here I am with my channel and hopefully
I continue to get better but it's always
because I expect a second to beginning
step number two is watch your language
this is really important you need to
watch the language that you say
especially to yourself you can ask other
people to catch it for you but you try
to catch it yourself anytime you hear
yourself saying hard
difficult difficult or scary hard
difficult or scary let that be a trigger
it's a trigger you're not allowed to say
that anymore that is not an acceptable
reason for you not to do something why
are you not going to make a video uh
because it's hard nope because it's
difficult nope because it's scary nope
no you do hard you do difficult you do
scary you love it you want to do hard
difficult and scary what's the opposite
the opposite of hard difficult and scary
is you do things that you are already
good at that are inside your comfort
zone thus you hate your life if there's
nothing in your calendar for the next
week next month that is hard difficult
or scary you hate your life you're just
photocopying the same day over and over
and over and over again you want
something more you know you're capable
of something more that's how it happens
and so it's a great little asset test
it's a great reminder that every time
you hear yourself saying it it's go time
you have to go do it you have to just
because you said it and have the people
around you call you out on it too your
husband your wife your kids your friends
your family your community people around
you if you ever answer a question I'm
not going to do it because it's hard
because it's difficult or because it's
scary it's not an acceptable answer
anymore because you do hard you do
difficult and you love scary and then
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort applaud the effort
regardless of the result I had a recent
podcast with my friend Mark jger and I
asked him Mark I need you to celebrate a
point where you were proud of your
effort but you didn't get a result cuz
he's so tied to getting results which is
great but if you only tie yourself forth
to getting results you're going to take
small bets you're only going to play
inside your comfort zone and thus you
play small for life so I said when was
the last time that you were so proud of
your effort even though you didn't get a
result and couldn't think of something
on the spot that's the problem that's
the problem you're not rewarding it
enough tie yourself Worth to the effort
what have you done today or what will
you do today this week this month that
you're proud of the effort even if the
result is zero even if the result is
negative you put up a video that you're
you're working your face off to try to
record and get out you spend a whole day
recording it you finally get one you
post it and everybody laughs at you it's
a negative result most people probably
won't even care but let's say you get a
negative awesome I'm pumped for you I'm
pumped for you I use the example when
people are afraid to ask me questions in
workshops or semon ours um and they
finally come up and they do something
whether it's just asking a question or
performing or making a video or or
singing or whatever their talents are
come up and do it come on up come on up
and do it and they're nervous and
they're shy and a lot of these people
have been sitting on this talent for 5
10 years and they haven't expressed it
yet cuz theyve been too afraid and I
tell them even if you come up and and
you just vomit all over the
place you V you vomit all over me I am
pumped for you cuz you tried cuz you
stood up and you tried cuz if you got up
every day and did that and you tied
yourself Worth to your effort instead of
the results the results there are
terrible right really negative you
vomited on somebody it's it's pretty bad
but if you got up every day and were
proud of your effort you got up again
and you did it again and again and again
and again I promise you you'll get
results and way bigger results than if
you just did things that kept you in
your comfort zone also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight our
favorite lessons from the video that
will inspire you to remember what you
learned today and actually apply them
the worksheet will also give you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there rule number three
don't try to please everybody so listen
everybody's going to have an opinion on
what you should do with your life
everybody your your friends your family
your culture your Society your community
your customers online haters everybody's
got an opinion on what you should do
with your life and it's tempting to want
to take the advice one because it gives
us advice but two it's also somebody to
blame right like if it doesn't work out
it's not my fault it's that person
person's fault they said I should do it
at some point though you have to decide
that you are going to be an adult that
you are in control that you want to go
off and build your own life and you only
you know what that looks like and you
have to have the courage and the
confidence to step up and say I'm in
charge this is my life now I get to
decide what I want to do and some
opinions will matter and some opinions
will make a difference and others you
have to let bounce off you you're not
going to be able to please everybody
everybody has an opinion on what you
should do with your life and the only
one that really matters truly is this
one right here so how do you decide how
do you know what the difference is how
do you know which opinions you should
take which you should listen to because
on the one hand it's you want to take
advice you want to take counsel you
don't know everything and on the other
hand it's it's your life you got to
decide how do you make those two things
work together I'm going to give you
three ideas that I think could really
help you number one is understand what
your one word is your one word is your
most important core value mine is
believe yours is whatever it is it's
worth going through the exercise I think
it's one of the most important exercises
you can ever do in your life it becomes
a filter through which you see the world
and so for me it's believe and believe
is around believing in yourself having
self-confidence believing in the work
that you're doing having passion for it
and believing that it's going to work
out believing in the impact believing
that there is light at the end of the
tunnel even if you only see Darkness
around you right now that's Bel and so
all of the decisions that I make are
through the lens of believe every new
piece of content that I put on my
channel is through the lens of belief
and so if you give me advice that has
nothing to do with believe it may be
great potential advice but it's not for
me how do I know what's for me because
I'm sitting on my rock of believe and if
you don't know what value you stand on
it's easy to get pulled in a lot of
different directions it's easy to look
at somebody else's life and say I want
to be like that no I want to be like
that no oh maybe you're right I should
go over here you don't have confidence
because you don't know who you are and
so the starting point is figuring out
what your one word is because that is at
the core it's your most important core
value so someone might say from my
YouTube channel hey you should profile
file the top stupidest mistakes that
this person has made or the the top most
hateful things that that person said you
know or the top reasons why this
person's an idiot chances are those
videos would actually blow up you know
people like negativity more than
positivity unfortunately I'm not going
to make those videos it's not believe
right I want to spread positivity and
hope and optimism that's what I want to
spread in the content that I put out and
so it's an easy note even though from a
strategy point of view it might be a
great thing to blow up my channel I
don't want to go down that path it's not
believe and so when you understand what
your one word most important core value
is it becomes the filter for your entire
life your entire business and as
questions and feedback and suggestions
come into you it becomes that filter so
you can make better decisions step
number two was the boom boom boom boom
test and what I mean by that is if your
heart is going boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom like you're nervous
somebody suggests something to you and
it sounds exciting but you're nervous
and you're scared then you have to go
and do that thing you have to go and do
that thing just to teach yourself that
you were the kind of person who when
you're nervous when you're scared when
you're fearful you jump into it you
attack it you want to beat it because if
you want to go off and do some crazy big
thing right we're entrepreneurs we got a
big crazy mission that we're trying to
go off and save the world from something
right we want to spread our message if
you can't do this one little scary thing
in front of you you can't do that
there's no way you're going to go off
and accomplish that big thing and so
train yourself anytime your heart is
being nervous right is boom you're
scared of doing something you're called
upon you're asked to rise to a challenge
you're nervous you're fearful you're
scared go and do that thing just to show
yourself that you can that's how you
actually build self-respect that's how
you actually build self-confidence it's
when you feeling afraid and you jump in
and do it anyway I don't believe in be
Fearless I don't think you can be
Fearless I think if you're Fearless on a
daily basis it means you're playing life
so small that nothing scares you I think
it's feeling the fear and doing it
anyway it's feeling the fear and saying
I'm scared of this and I'm the kind of
person who Rises to a challenge and I'm
going to go off and attack it and so
when you get a suggestion when somebody
gives you an opinion is it something
that you actually want to do is it
something that makes you scared and if
yes then you have to go off and do that
thing just to show yourself that you can
and the third filter is what will you
regret if you get hit with a suggestion
somebody says you should do this think
about will you regret not doing it we
very rarely regret the things that we do
we regret the things that we didn't do
we regret the actions not taken and so
when you get hit with a
suggestion and you want to do it but
you're afraid and we got the boom boom
boom test already imagine your life at
100 years old fast forward you're at the
end of your life you're sitting on your
rocking chair you're you're in some
retirement home life is almost over for
you and look back at the past Decades of
your life will you regret not having
taken action on it this is the thing I
use to help push me through fear as well
if somebody suggests hey you should go
do an interview with this person and I'm
afraid that means I have to do it but
also I fast forward to 100 years old and
said I could have done that you know I
could have done that I could have made
that thing happen but I didn't and I've
lived the past 40 50 60 70 80 years
depending on how old you are with regret
and so I imagine it as I've got you know
something stuck in my tooth something
stuck in my tooth I can't get it out and
and it's bothering me but then I punch
myself in the arm oh that hurt I punched
hard I punch myself in the arm until I
don't feel the toothache anymore I don't
feel that thing sucking between my teeth
that's what regret can be used for you
don't want to live in the regret 24/7
you don't want to live in the negativity
and the fear 24/7 but in moments when
you feel like you're about to play small
in moments when you can hit with this
opinion or suggestion that you know it's
the right thing for you but you're
afraid that it's not going to work out I
use that fear of regret to make it so
big in the moment that I have to go off
and do that thing that's what helped me
get my YouTube channel going that's what
helped me do my presentations and my
tours and my speaking gigs and my books
and all of these things I'm scared I'm
afraid to do it I imagine myself at 100
and say if I don't write that book If I
don't make those YouTube videos if I
don't go and interview that person if I
don't try to push my 10 million
subscriber goal if I don't do it I'm
going to regret it for the rest of my
life and that fear forces me into
positive action to go off and do it rule
number four stop judging yourself making
decisions for your life based off of
what other people expect you to do is
the fastest way to hate your life most
people actually hate their lives most
people are not doing the thing that they
could be great at and they're judging
you for you going off and chasing down
your dream listening to them is the
fastest way to crush your dreams and
never achieve the Michael Jordan level
greatness that you have inside you
you're a weird duck this is one thing
that I've learned from all my travels
from all the entrepreneurs I visited
around the world I'm a weird duck and so
are you you're a weird duck you like
weird things you're not normal you don't
want to be normal you don't want to be
normal you do not want to be normal and
yet you judge yourself based off of what
other people expect a normal person to
do and it's time to stop and and I'm
leaning into it more and more and more
and more and more and I hope I can give
you permission to lean into it more and
more and more as
well I'm here at beautiful Puerto Rico
we're taking a walk down the beach
earlier today with my wife Nina and
we're supposed to film but the the sound
on the beach is crazy hopefully you can
still hear it here it still got some
wind but on the water it's a crazy windy
day so we came back up the film and as I
was walking I did a quick Instagram
video of just my feet in the sand and
somebody dm'd me as a response to say
man if I was there I'd have a really
hard time focusing on work
and I responded I can't wait to get back
to my room to go film like this is
beautiful I love it it's amazing right
like what a scenery I'm blessed to be
here grateful that I can have the kind
of business that allows me to travel and
and see these awesome places but I love
the work I love working I love making
videos for you guys I can't wait to plan
you know the next week the next month
the next quarter for what I'm going to
be doing in my business I love it after
I'm done filming you know what we're
going to do we're going to go down on
the beach we're going to go down there
see those see those see those chairs
right there we're going to go down there
Nina's going to work on her tan probably
pass out that's the goal she wants to
try to sleep I'm going to be working I'm
going to be working I'm going to be I'm
going to be looking at my YouTube stats
I'm going to be planning my membership
course I'm going to be looking at my
YouTube growth boot camp I'm going to be
working on the book launch I'm going to
be work and I love
it I love it and that's weird that's not
what that's not what most of these
people want to do right that's not what
that's not what these guys want to do
that's not what but most people come to
a place like this to escape a life that
they hate they come to a place like this
for a couple days or for a week to
escape a life that they hate they can
run away that's want to lie on the beach
and forget my life forget that that
world exists and just Escape I think
that's a huge mistake there's nothing
wrong if you love the beach you love the
ocean you love the weather it's
beautiful weather coming from Toronto
Canada we're buried under snow right now
so this is beautiful weather there's
nothing wrong with that but what's
better is fixing your
life if you're looking forward to your
next vacation that's amazing CU you're
looking forward to it but not because
you're trying to run away from something
and that's what most people are doing
that's what most people are doing the
run away from a life that they
hate it's not the path and these are the
people whose opinions you're worried
about the people people who wake up
every day go to a job that they hate so
that once a year they can come on a
vacation like this are telling you that
you suck that you're crazy that you
shouldn't be doing this crazy thing they
gave up on their dreams years ago don't
let that infect you and it's not that
they suck and that you need to put them
down but you can't let that toxicity
seep into
yourself and so it starts by
understanding that yeah you are weird
you love weird you Embrace weird anytime
my son Hayden who's 10 somebody calls
him weird at school we we fist bump that
boom awesome of course we're weird you
don't want to be normal who wants to be
normal so one embrace the weird embrace
the different you're a weird duck that's
bad ass that's amazing love it own it
and then two whatever it is that you
want to do that makes you weird go off
and do it as long as it's not hurting
somebody
else get into the practice of expressing
yourself get into the practice practice
of living your life more out loud not to
try to show off and say hey look at me
but just to get comfortable with living
your life and not having the opinions of
the people who are looking at you impact
you have empathy for them if somebody's
hating on you if somebody's telling you
that you shouldn't do it that you're
crazy that you suck have empathy for
them cuz that person that person
guaranteed hates their life they hate
their life so look at their life do you
want to life like them do you want to
live like them do you want a mindset
like them do you want to wake up and
think like them and have their habits
and routine no hell no no no so why are
you listening to them self-confidence
self-respect self-love comes from doing
difficult things comes from doing the
things that you might get judged for
everything you want that's great out of
life your dreams your Ambitions the big
goals you have will come with other
people judging you saying that you can't
do it and so you must
you must make the choice to decide are
you going to live out loud live your
version of your life instead of what
other people boring people people who
hate their life who are living a
mediocrity want for
you decision time rule number five the
last one before our very special bonus
clip do difficult things self-esteem
comes from doing difficult things you
set a goal you said start doing
something and maybe even you do actually
start doing that thing but then you hit
a roadblock then it gets difficult it
gets hard and what you do in that moment
will Define the rest of your life when
it's hard when it's difficult do you
rise to the occasion or do you let
yourself off again finding some really
logical reason why you can't do that
thing it doesn't count until it's hard
you don't grow until it's hard you don't
build self-respect self-esteem
self-confidence until it's hard and you
follow through I keep these in my office
as a reminder of who I am of who I am in
my best moments my best self to push me
to do more and to push harder what what
are these if you're new to my channel
welcome I'm Evan uh I went on a tour at
the beginning of this year I did a tour
23 cities 90 days and 2third of the way
through with a month left I broke my
neck when I was in Denver I fainted I
fell of a chair I hit my head against
the wall crack my the back of my head
open I had three Staples on my head I
had a concussion and I broke my neck in
two spots and after that night I had to
wear this I had to wear this for the
next oh I just noticed this note here
Nina signed it I love you get well soon
Nina she signed it that's that's sweet a
got to go thank her anyway had a little
motional moment there I broke my neck
and I decided to keep going on my tour I
had a month left everybody was telling
me to go home my agent told me to go
home my friends my family said come home
get get the health care you need relax
stay in bed rest you need to recover and
I said being with entrepreneurs is my
recovery and pushing through and doing
this tour is my healing one physical
healing because just sitting on the bed
all day is not going to be for someone
like me uh something that's amazing but
two just just pushing through and
knowing that I can right it doesn't
count until it's hard it doesn't count
until it's difficult and then you get up
and you do it and so if you've seen any
of the videos or pictures of me at the
events I went from standing up and
moving around and having energy to then
I had to sit at the front of a room with
pillows behind me and an ice pack on my
shoulder blade for three and a half 4
hours in massive pain the whole time
answering questions and doing my
workshop and I was so proud of myself
for doing it that's how I built my
self-esteem by getting up and doing
doing it by showing up and it inspired
the people who came out they're saying
well you know I live 25 minutes away
didn't know if I wanted to make the
drive I commit to it I was kind of tired
and then I saw you with your broken neck
still showing up so I had to show up too
right but that's not why I did it I did
it for me I did it for myself I had to
wear this all day all night long this
was my first one and then it started to
break so Nina put some duct tape on it
here and then this this was my second
one one that once it started to really
wind down I couldn't wear it anymore I
went for this one and 10 minutes a day
is all I could do to take it off for a
shower so I had to sleep in this I had
to do my workshop in this
everything 23 hours and 50 minutes a day
except for a 10-minute break in the
shower where I took it off and was
paranoid about moving anything because
my neck was broken I had to keep it
stabilized I wore
these this reminds me of how strong I am
so big shout out to Mark drer friend of
the channel who said hey you should keep
those as souvenirs as momentos and I'm
not a super sentimental guy so I don't
usually do that but I did I kept I kept
them both and I I keep them on my shelf
down there behind me so when I walk in
to the office it reminds me of how
strong I am doing the workshop tour was
already a stretch because it was a paid
tour that I was afraid to do and
disappointing people as my number one
fear and so getting up every 3 4 days
and having a chance to face my fear
again uh was already Big Stretch for me
but then doing that last month with my
broken neck just up the ante up my level
up the challenge and so when it gets
hard this is it this is the example when
it gets hard when everybody tells you
just back off don't worry about it even
when there's that voice inside your head
that says Ah is that a little too much
you know you could just sleep you could
just relax you've earned it what's going
to make you proud and at the end of the
day this is the only thing that you
could judge for yourself I would not
have been proud of myself if I left the
tour I would have had a lot of good
reasons to do it I wouldn't have felt
proud of myself and so I had to keep
going that's what made me proud that's
what got me through on the other side
and it took me to another level it
doesn't count until it's hard you will
be challenged you'll be faced with
difficulties you will have every reason
in the world to slow down to stop to
quit what's going to make you proud go
do that thing there's a three step
process I want to walk you through I
think will help let's Dive In Step
number one is you tell yourself you do
difficult things I want to develop that
identity for myself and I want it for
you you do difficult things you love
difficult things what's the reason why
you're not doing the thing that you want
to do go look yourself in the mirror and
ask yourself why am I not doing the
thing that I said I was going to do if
the answer comes back that is it's
difficult it's not an acceptable answer
it's hard is not an acceptable answer
you love doing hard things you only want
to do hard difficult things what's the
alternative easy you want easy all day
long you can get it it's easy you want
easy anybody can live easy it just means
you do the same thing over and over and
over again you photocopy yesterday and
the day before and the day before you
photocopy your life every day you can
live like you did yesterday and the day
before for the rest of your life just
doing the same thing waking up going to
a job that you hate doing that all over
that's easy you don't like it cuz humans
are built to grow you want to grow you
want progress you want to be learning
and that comes by doing difficult things
you love difficult things if you don't
have something in your calendar that is
difficult in the next week you don't
like your life and so watch your
language watch how you're speaking out
to people and you're explaining things
but also just to yourself what you think
about oh but it's so hard nope you do
hard things you love hard things ask the
people around you to catch it anytime
you say something is difficult or hard
catch it tell me throw water on my face
let me know and then go and do that
thing and then watch your self-esteem
your self-confidence your self- resect
Skyrocket number two is use regret to
fuel you you very rarely regret the
things that you have done you you regret
the things not done you regret the
things that you wanted to do that you
should have done that you you you wanted
to take your shot at but you you're just
afraid you're just afraid it's normal as
human nature we're afraid we're afraid
of the new but you want to do that thing
and so I don't recommend using past
regrets that much because you can't
change the past but future ones this
thing that you want to do imagine that
you never do it this thing that you have
this idea in your head of you speaking
on stage or making videos or launching
that product or winning that award
whatever the thing is that's in your
head you never do it it never happens
because you're afraid you never take
that step because you're afraid you
never make that phone call because
you're afraid you never send that email
record that video you know press that
red button you never do it cuz you're
afraid you're afraid you're afraid
you're afraid you're afraid you never
take action cuz you're afraid now what
now you're 85 years old and you haven't
done
anything and just feel how hard that
hurts feel it that
sucks and what it does is bring all that
pain and fear of the next X number of
decades into today's moment to force you
into action because you have to do that
thing you want to do that thing it's
better to know and to fail than to not
know you don't want to live your whole
life not
knowing so use the future fear of regret
to push you into immediate action and
number three is tell yourself it's the
best if you hang around me long enough
you'll start saying it it's the best and
I use it as a trigger that anytime
there's something negative happening
around me from a big thing to a small
thing you rewire yourself to say this is
the best this is the best this is my
chance to show myself and the world what
I'm made of this is the best whatever
problem is in front of you even
yesterday I was making coffee
Bulletproof Coffee you have to put
coffee coffee in a blender with with
milk or butter and MCT oil and if you
want some collagen you throw it in there
turn the blender on and it and it goes
when I do cream I just keep the blender
on low cuz you don't have to blend it
that much and I don't have a cap on but
for whatever reason I turned the thing
on and for the first time ever the whole
machine exploded on
me coffee everywhere all over the
countertop all over the floor all over
the cabinets coffee is everywhere it's
part of my morning routine now I'm
behind now I got to clean this mess up
I'm behind I'm going to fall behind
everything else I need to
do it's the best this is the best this
is the best cuz what's the alternative
just complain about it if you believe
like I believe that your purpose comes
from your pain that that negative thing
that happen to you even in the in the
biggest sense I'm just talking about
coffee who cares but the big things that
are negative to happen to you are
actually the best too CU you get defined
by it either way those challenges that
get thrown in front of your face you get
defined by it either way
either you then take on the identity
that you can't handle difficult things
and you succumb and you become negative
and complain and drag other people down
with you or you take the approach that
this negative thing that happened is the
best and I'm going to learn from it and
I'm going to grow from it and then I'm
going to make sure that nobody else on
the planet ever has to go through that
crazy scary impossible painful thing
that you went through that's why I love
helping entrepreneurs cuz I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur myself I want to
try to make the path a little bit easier
for you compared to what I had to go
through so it's the best
so try to catch it try to teach yourself
whenever you get faced with a negative
situation no matter how big or small
just tell yourself this this thing right
here is the
best you need to create an environment
of Excellence Excellence most people's
environments are not excellent the
people around you the the videos that
you watch the things that are on your
wall the voices that are in your head
you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal minimal minimal improvements in
their life year over year and if you
don't want to stay where you are right
now fast forward to one year from today
you don't want to say stuck you want to
be in a different place could actually
be physically moving but a different
place in terms of your finances in terms
of your purpose in terms of how much
you're giving and caring and sharing and
the life that you want to build you want
to be somewhere totally different like
today this is not acceptable anymore I I
accept that this is where I am right now
but where I end up is not going to be
the same spot as where I am right now
right if that's your commitment the
biggest shift that will help you get
from where you are now to where you want
to be is creating that environment of
Excellence what's the fastest way to
learn a language what's the fastest way
to learn Japanese well it's to go to
Japan sure you can read some books and
and you can hire a tutor and that the
more intense it becomes the more you're
actually living it the faster you're
going to pick it up so if you want to
develop the mindset of the high achiever
if you want to become that person the
people that you look at up to the the
whoever of the world like I want to be
the next whoever perfect that person the
more you hang around with them the more
it's going to rub off on you how they
think cuz how they think how they act
how they behave how they see the world
is very different than how you see it
right now and how the people around you
definitely see the world right now so
how do you do it how do you start to
become it well I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief I'm trying to solve the
world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough I don't you
don't Oprah doesn't people don't believe
in themselves enough for the next level
so how do you start to believe in
yourself more the thing that helped me
the most was to have these successful
people around me
constantly and so I want to share a few
tactics that I think can really help you
that has really helped me as being the
shy introvert ed kid who never wanted to
be in front of a a camera and was making
300 bucks a month and quit on my
business partner and thought life was
over right to to now here and it's taken
me 20 years to get here so hopefully we
can shorten that path for you if you
actually follow some of the advice in
this video so step number one how do we
create that environment of
Excellence what you feed into your brain
really really really matters so figure
out how you love to learn for me it's
videos I like to see things I need to be
visual if that's you then you need to
have a way to have those videos coming
into your life every day it could be
part of your morning routine that's why
I make this channel part of your morning
routine subscribe to the channel every
morning every weekday we got a new video
out there for you to give you the shot
of andpress that to help you but if it's
not my channel it's some other channel
one of my other channels subscribe to
the channels that make you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable give you hope give
you belief in yourself and then watch
that video every day or listen to that
podcast every day or read that book
every day the trick is it can't be the
same book of this the the one video
because that one video on repeat is
going to lose its Effectiveness right
you know it you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good you
watch it the next day and the feeling is
gone so you can't just read the same
book over and over watch the same video
over and over and over again the key is
to find a consistent source so if you
love this Channel or you love this video
I'm making other videos just like this
that you can subscribe to if you like an
author go find their other books or go
find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are manipulating
what comes in your head with intention
now with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward cuz it'll
happen if you love Elon Musk and you
watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him so
be careful who you pick and maybe you
don't like Elon Musk maybe you like
Kanye West or opro wify or whoever but
the more you're around that person the
more you will start to think like them
so you want to put that as part of your
daily routine that every day cuz
yesterday was a different day you might
have been fired up bold motivated great
but today's today's a new day the
motivation you had yesterday is nowhere
near what it is right now when you wake
up right you get have the best day of
all time you wake up the next day and
it's gone so how do you keep the
consistency the
routine you tell yourself I'm going to
watch a video even when I don't want to
even when I feel low energy even when
right all the excuses we come up with
I'm going to watch a video to get myself
into the state I need to get into
because I want to follow I want to
follow my dreams I don't want to be
stuck here
anymore tied to that is then subscribe
to the
channels that make you feel that way so
do an audit of all of the channels you
follow on YouTube of all the people you
follow on Instagram anywhere you're
spending time on
social do an audit of who makes you
actually feel more
bold and who makes you just waste time
or who makes you feel bad about yourself
there's some people you probably follow
who when you look at their stuff it
actually makes you feel worse about
yourself unfollow those people
immediately right they don't care about
you so why are you caring about them and
then the people who make you feel better
follow them subscribe to them so that
when you happen to be on the platform
when you happen to be throwing going
through YouTube or Instagram you see
them and it makes you remember why
you're doing what you do so the first
part of it is a habit we we are
designing our routines around this that
I'm going to watch a video every day
with my heroes so that they pull me
forward right we're putting into our
calendar the second part of it is I'm
also going to subscribe to channels and
people that inspire me so that when I
happen to be on the platforms I'm
feeding myself with things that inspire
me and lift me up instead of waste my
time or put me down okay so that habit
that environment really really matters
the second part of environment to create
our environment of Excellence right is
the physical environment so this office
inspires me this office this was all
with intent the people on the wall
behind me we got Steve Jobs AP janini my
parents Howard Schultz Kanye West the
trophies uh you know the YouTube stuff
the the the getting getting my hands
wrong here this side you know the art
the art that people drew my book uh my
neck brace from when I broke my neck
like all even the colors on the wall all
of this it inspires me this inspires me
when I walk into this office I I want to
believe more in myself I see Steve Jobs
stearing me down I see my parents
staring me down it's like a reminder of
what I want to do cuz I wake up and I
and I don't have you know the the the
most energy I don't feel super bold and
like let's go take on the day right I I
don't have that as soon as I wake up but
we manufacture it through the habits and
routines but also the actual physical
environment and the beauty about this is
you only have to set it up once you know
I set this up once and then I walk in
and every day I'm being hit with these
messages and reminders of the person
that I want to be so whether it's a mood
board you put up for yourself whether
there's people that inspire you you have
to look at the thing that inspires you
to want to push a little harder it
inspires you to want to believe in
yourself and more it inspires you to
want to go off and take some kind of
today the physical environment matters a
lot and you can control that so think
about think about your office think
about your bedroom think about your car
think about where you're spending
significant time and how much of that
has actually been done with
intent how much of your physical
environment has been created with intent
to make you believe in yourself more it
matters a lot and then the third thing
really quick is the actual your outfit
the clothes that you wear how you show
up for yourself when I put this on
I remind myself that I'm a superhero
going to work that might sound really
dumb or cheesy but you know what it
works for me I am a superhero going to
work I'm not fighting crime I'm fighting
lack of belief I want people to believe
in themselves more and I'm going to work
uh when I see there was a a green arrow
show I used to watch and when they were
in their their base in their layer they
always put their outfits on a mannequin
right so they're when they're off
fighting crime they're in their uniforms
then when they come back to their base
they they're in normal clothes but they
put their outfits on a mannequin so I
went and got myself a mannequin it's
it's just you can't see it but it's just
sitting here off camera I got a
mannequin and it's got my hoodie on it
as a reminder that I'm a superhero going
to work every day and again that might
sound really cheesy or dumb or corny but
I like it it works for me and putting
this on every day instead of just
showing up in my pajamas I just I work
from home you know we've got 30
something people on the team uh I I
don't see my team physically that often
most people work from home I could just
show up every day in my
pajamas but putting this on reminds me
that I'm a superhero with a
mission whether you want to adopt that
or not is up to you but but how you
present yourself for yourself not just
for the camera I'm not putting this on
just for the camera I'm putting this on
cuz this is what I put on this is for
me I could make make a video of my
pajamas that's fine but I'm making this
for me I wear this for me what do you
need to do for you not just because
there's some expectations when your
expectations of yourself become higher
than what you think other people's
expectations are for you that's when the
game starts to change when I'm wearing
something just because of how I think
you guys will perceive me or or some
speech I'm doing or some
meeting I'm I'm only living up to that
person's standards or what I think their
standards are and said no I'm doing this
for me I wear this for me I show up like
this even if I'm not making any kind of
content I only make content once a week
usually for YouTube what are the what am
I doing the other days of the week I'm
still wearing this cuz I'm a superhero
going to work and it's my reminder this
is how you start to create an
environment of Excellence guys your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment is keeping you stuck
and if you don't want to be stuck
anymore if you want to change your
circumstances if you don't want to be in
the same spot you are right now one year
from today you have to create an
environment of Excellence how do we do
that number one we start feeding our
mind with Excellence from the videos and
podcasts and books from people who
Inspire Us number two we change our
physical environment so that you walk
into a room you walk into your car you
walk into your bedroom or office or
wherever you're spending time and it
pushes you forward to step into the
person that you want to be and then
number three The Outfits what you wear
how you present yourself having a higher
standard for yourself than what other
people expect that you are a super
superhero going to work every day cuz
you are on a mission you've got a great
heart you've got tons of
ideas I see it over and over and over
and over and over
again so much
potential and just stuck just
stuck because there's a lack of momentum
that stems from having a really poor
environment if you can just change with
intention that I'm going to create an
environment of Excellence for myself
that inspires me and pushes me forward
to step into the person I want to
believe that I can be you can do that
every day your entire life will change
the reason why you're not following
through is because you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else it's
just massively difficult to follow
through still possible absolutely but
this this is the life of an entrepreneur
this is why so many great entrepreneurs
don't follow through and it breaks my
heart because you've Got Talent you've
got a desire to serve and to help and
you know you have a story that matters
and you're just not as consistent as you
know you could be and it's not that you
suck it's just that you're doing it
alone this is something I've struggled
with in terms of being a great resource
for people because I actually have a
very low community need I think the
journey that I went through
is almost impossible to model because I
just woke up every day and I still made
videos and I still made content and I
did it by myself and it's not
prescriptive it's really difficult to do
it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it but I have a really low
maybe it's just introverted or or uh
what whatever but I just don't need it
as much as most people you probably need
more Community you probably are not
following through because you feel
isolated and alone and the great promise
of Entrepreneurship is freedom right
it's like you don't have to have a boss
you don't get to you don't have to have
employees that you hate or people on
your team who you hate you know you get
to pick everything you want but then to
go from having a job where you have
Community even if it even if you didn't
enjoy the work you were doing what you
got from the job if youve one is
community that you had co-workers and
you had some people who you did like and
you had people to go to lunch with and
you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that nearly
as much or at all and so it's very
lonely and it's really hard to do great
work when when you're
lonely so what's the
solution like okay great yeah you just
tore my heart open Evan now what do I do
how do I fix it well first is just
recognizing that that that is a problem
you know first is recognizing that
there's nothing wrong with you there's
nothing wrong with you you're amazing
the only problem is you just don't have
anybody that you're collaborating with
that you're doing this by yourself so
the answer is we need to now go and find
other people to collaborate with nobody
wants to work with somebody who doesn't
have integrity but what is integrity
what does that mean for you how do you
find it how do you know what you stand
for for me it all comes down to values
when you understand what you stand for
as human being when you know what your
most important core value is then you
know how to live with integrity and you
know how to build a business based
around Integrity as well and so the
process that I go through is your one
word I wrote a book about it you can
read it you can pick it up and
understand how to apply it to your
business and your life but at the core
is figuring out if I had to stand for
one thing as a human being what is that
thing and so a quick process let's go
through this quick exercise together you
can pick up the book later right now
think about one who is your favorite
teacher growing up you've had lot lots
of teachers growing up through High
School University Elementary School who
was your favorite teacher it wasn't
because they taught you grade 10 math
there was a reason what was it who was
the person and what was it two what was
your favorite movie growing up pick your
favorite movie and why and then three
who's your favorite entrepreneur who's
the person you look up to the most who
did you learn the most from who do you
most want to emulate if I run through
that scenario for myself number one my
favorite teacher is madam far growing up
at my school Crescent school she always
believed in me she always helped me she
always guided me she helped take me from
being a b student to A+ student in my
final year she made me feel like it was
possible two my favorite movie is seab
biscuit it's about this racehorse that's
too small and a jockey that's too big
and an owner that has no money and a
trainer that's down on his luck and they
all seem to come together to built this
race horse that goes off and wins a
whole bunch of races and helps lift the
nation based off a true story I've seen
that movie at least 30 times three my
favorite entrepreneur is AP janini he
started Bank of America he was the guy
who first gave immigrants in America
money as a loan he lent money to People
based off of a handshake and a look in
their eye if you can imagine he gave
Walt Disney the money to have his first
featurelength cartoon and everybody
thought he was crazy and so what's a
Common Thread through all that between
Madam far C biscuit AP janini they may
all seem totally disconnected they're
not if I had to write down three
characteristics this is what you should
do you write down your three names and
then you have three characteristics for
each one the word believe pops off the
sheet for me I think about all of them
and believe comes out Madame far
believed in me my other teachers are
really nice they really helped me it was
amazing but she really helped move the
nil because she believed in me Sea
Biscuit I've seen lots of movies I love
them all it's great but the the idea of
Believe coming through that
racehorse I love it it's a cheesy movie
but I love it and then AP janini is the
beli banker let money to the people and
bet on them when nobody else believed in
them my one word is belief as a result
I've built my entire business around it
right my life and my business are built
around belief my videos my newsletter my
website my speaking gigs the books that
I write everything I create it's not
just a strategy it's a way of living and
that's having Integrity with yourself so
why don't I make a top 10 video series
on the stupidest things that people say
because it's anti-b belief cuz it's
negative my channel would actually be
bigger if I did the negative side of
things people would rather be
entertained and laugh at others than
educate themselves and get better people
would rather sit at home and watch 4
hours of Netflix every night then go off
and spend four hours learning and trying
to build a business they just would we'd
rather be entertained and educated but I
don't want to be in that business I
don't want to be in a negative business
I don't want to be in the hater business
because my one word is believe and so
that's having Integrity with myself and
then Integrity with you guys my audience
my customers the people that I work with
and so yes Integrity is at the core of
everything if you don't have integrity
people do not want to work with you but
how do you figure out what that means of
course you're not going to go lie to
somebody right of course stealing is
going to be bad but what else how do you
get more specific the biggest problem is
lack of clarity people don't know what
they stand for and as a result you're
living up to other people's expectations
and versions where I want you to live
inside yourself I want you to be
standing on a rock when everybody else
is sending on quicksand you have Clarity
you have definiteness of purpose and it
starts with figuring out your one word
so you can pick up the book or you can
go through that three-step process think
about who your favorite teacher was and
why write three words down for it think
about what your favorite movie is and
why write three words down for it and
think about who your favorite
entrepreneur or hero is of all time and
why write three words down from it look
at what's similar your one word will pop
off the page and now you know what
integrity means to
you and if you want to watch Evan's top
10 rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
so I say two things the first is just
staying consistent on the thing I don't
know how many times it took you to make
a video before your channel started to
take off uh for me it was a lot 5 years
to get to 2,000 subscribers